是这一讲的主讲人段谱
我是蚂蚁集团共享智能的一名自身技术专家
在这一讲中我会给大家带来两个密码学的基础概念
一个是安全求交级另外一个是你宗查寻
因为这是两个不同的技术
虽然他们有一些共同的地方
通过我们的学习大家就会学习到这些共同的地方
但这两个技术它
基于的很多密码学的源源还是不一样的
所以我还是会分为两个部分来介绍
分别介绍这两门技术
所以在
第一部分中我会先介绍一下安全求交级
在第二部分中我会介绍你宗查寻
对于安全求交级我会分为五个小的部分来介绍这门技术
在第一个小部分我会讲一下安全求交级的定义
也就是psi的定义psi是安全求交级的缩写
第二部分我会基于psi
也就是安全求交级的一些不同功能
对它进行一些分类和简介
第三部分我会介绍psi它最新的一些学术界的进展
第四部分是psi和其他隐私计算技术的一些结合
第五部分是reference list
也就是在我这一讲中
我可能会去介绍到一些psi的
著名的论文和包括一些最新的论文
如果感兴趣的同学下来可以根据reference list的进去
找到这些论文来学习这些学习更多的细节
首先安全求交级psi的定义
psi它的英文称呼是private-side-intersection
所以执意过来就是安全求交级
它的缩写是psi
去手字母
因为psi在隐私计算中
或者说在密码学中已经是发展比较久的一门技术了
一个分支
所以psi已经是一个密码学的术语
如果大家以后在密码学的文献中看到psi
那么很大概率它就指责是安全求交级这个技术
如右图所示
这就是一个psi的势力图
在这个图里头大家能看到
首先Alice有一个数据级X
然后Bob有一个数据级Y
然后经过一次psi的计算之后
Alice就拿到了他的数据级X和Bob数据级Y的一个交级
然后这里头的安全的要求是什么
Alice不能看到任何Bob在非交级中的元素
然后这里面的核心是说
Alice应该是会去通过很多方法去想去看到这些Bob的在非交级中的元素
就是Bob有些元素
他们没再跟Alice的交级中是Bob自己独有的Alice可能想去知道
但是安全求交级这种密码学的定义应该保证了
即使Alice去想这些方法
去得到这些Bob的这些额外的信息
他是拿不到的
然后这里面安全求交级因为是密码学的
所以是一个协议
所以他是要求能够可证安全的
然后我们可能再思考一下
一般来说在这个时间里很多这种psi的这种讲座
它就会根据不同的psi基于的不同的技术
然后对psi进行一个分类
然后来讲解psi
但是我在这一讲中我觉得我们想做一些不一样的这种讲解方式
首先我会还是会先介绍一些最基础的psi的协议
因为这个是你了解psi的一个最最基础的部分
然后只有这样才能了解我们怎么样去设计一个psi
就是说从high level 来说怎么去设计psi协议
然后在这之后我们可以思考一下
我们有了一个最基础的一个最基本的psi协议
那么我们还不需要什么功能
就是在限制生活中
也许最基本的psi协议不能满足我们所有的需求
对不对
那我们还需要什么额外的功能呢
我们可以发散自己的思维
多想一些其他的功能
然后我会再介绍基于这些可能的不同的功能
我们怎么样去有一些这种idea去设计这些不同的psi协议
所以第二部分我会先讲解一下psi的功能和分类
就是我刚才说的这个road map
是我会想讲解一个最基础的psi协议
基于这个大家可以同学们可以发散思维思考下
我们还需要什么不同功能的psi
最基础最常用的psi
一般我们说成它是一种叫to party semi honest的psi
我来一个一个解释这个数语
首先这个psi它是用来计算交集的
就像刚才最基础的定义
iLsBob iLs能看到交集
也就是说什么
交集是可以被双方或者一方看见的
双方两方都可以看见
或者其中一方能看见
然后我们想保护的是什么
想保护的是非交集元素
所以这里头有一个假设
就是密码学的假设
就是交集是属于双方共用的一个knowledge
所以交集是可以看的
然后我们还有一个最基础的psi
还有一个最基本的设置
是它是两方的一个psi
就像我们刚才土地说的是iLsBob
对吧
大家可能很容易想来
我可能不止两方
我是三方或者四方怎么办
这个就是我后续要讲到的
超出这种基础psi
它可能有一些变形
然后多放psi
还有一个很重要的密码学数语
就是说这个是
半城市安全
Semi honest to secure的
这是什么意思呢
这个psi里头如果有攻击者
举个例子iLsBob
可能任何一个人是攻击者
那么这个攻击人
他必须还是要严格的遵守协议
他不能任意的篡改协议
他严格的遵守和执行协议之后
在这之外
他可能会对另外一方的一些
隐私信息感兴趣
然后做一些那种叫密码学
叫pensive attack
可能是一些offline的一些
线下的一些分析
通过他拿到的一些message
是想推出
推算出另外一方的一些隐私信息
但这个攻击人是做不到的
所以这个叫半城市安全
这是密码学里头
最基础的一个安全模型
也是最低的安全模型
下来我来讲一下
如果我们想设计一个这种
最基本的to party semi honest to psi
我们应该怎么做
首先第一个挑战是
大家肯定能想到
我们一定要想一个方法
隐藏非交集元素
我们用英文说就是Heading
这里头这个核心的是
想法是什么
就是刚才Alice Bob的那个图里
对吧
就是Alice可能
我看到交集的
我还想知道Bob非交集的元素是什么
那么Bob的这些非交集元素
一定得要去想办法隐藏住
这个里面的隐藏是很强
是密码学定义的一种隐藏
就是它是Crypto Graphically Secure的Heading
也就是说在刚才我举的例子里
Alice
不管通过什么样的方法做分析
他可能都分析不出来
Bob的非交集元素是什么
如果想做这个
大家可以先这里给大家介绍一些
比较high-level的idea
那么很大的待遇
这种Heading
想做到这种Heading
我们是需要把一些噪音添加到这种元素里的
只有这种元素里头有了一定的噪音
这种非交集的元素
才不能够被穷举的计算出来
因为很多情况下
我们一会会看到一个例子
就是说
我如果用这种不安全的PSI协议
那么如果这个噪音没有添加的话
这是供给人是有概率去穷举来计算的
第二一个Challenge是说
我们需要计算交集元素
也就是说我们要有一个方法
能够做comparison
什么意思
当两个元素是相等的时候
那么相等性
就算在你满足Challenge 1
去隐藏非交集元素的时候
就算你添加的噪音
那么这些非交集元素
也就是它matching的这些element
还是他们的相等性
还是能够被计算出来的
这个要求是什么
就是说不能因为我添加的噪音
我两个元素相等
我就算不出来了
这个是不行的
所以可能一般很常用的一些密码学的
就是说大家举个例子
大家用各自的什么密码加密
然后来对比
这个就不行了
因为密码不一样
它加密出来的相同的元素
它的密文也不一样
所以就没有办法发现
这个相同的元素是相同的
所以Challenge 2是基于1
Challenge 1的一个更高的要求
第三个当然是更高界的一个要求
就是要效率高
因为其实psi是一个发展
比较久的隐私计算的一门技术了
然后它也是最简单的一种
大家可以理解成
就是多方安全计算的一种变形
因为它只是去计算相等性
所以我们的psi的效率是应该比较高的
下来我给大家介绍第一个方法
就是一种非常难意的
也就是说一种trivial的一个solution
就是psi based on this hash
首先我强调一下
这个不应该称作是一个psi鞋
因为psi都是安全的
这个应该是一种不安全的psi鞋
但是这是给大家一个这种比较rough idea
就是说怎么样去设计一个psi
这个想法特别简单
对吧
就是大家可能都了解
我就是Alice Boblow
我把自己的元素先hash
然后再做比较
那么这个hash function
这个里面肯定是一种密码学的hash function
它必须是有这种one way property
就是你不能逆着能算出来
我hash一个element得到一个结果
我看到这个结果
我想反推出这个input的是什么
是不行的
然后同时它还要需要clation resistance
就是说我不能有这个碰撞概率
就是这个碰撞的这个概率应该是几厘的
那么有一个hash function的话
就是密码的hash function
我怎么设计呢
很简单对吧
就是receiver sender
sender把自己所有的数据
我选hash了
hash function是公开的
然后我把hash的这个value送给receiver
receiver看到之后
我把receiver也把自己的x1到x
你也做做hash
跟sender的hy1和hyn做比较
如果一样
因为它就知道是一样的
如果不一样
那理论上就是从one way property
它也不能反推出对方是什么
对不对
那这个里头hiding是怎么保证的呢
是one way cryptographic hash function保证的
所以hash function就保证了
你的output不能直接推出来input
所以如果有一个
举个例子
有一个举个例子
hig的任何一个receiver元素都不一样
那么我想通过hig反推出
wig从hash function的角度上讲是不行的
对吧
还有一个要求是comparant
也就是说我两个相同的元素
经过同一个hash之后
我得到output了
肯定是一样的
这个大家也很容易理解
第三个就是效率
那hash function当然是非常高效的一种计算
那问题是什么呢
问题是这样的
如果这里面的所有的hx
大的x集合和y集合
它都是一个高商
high entropy的input data set
那么这个协议是ok的
举个例子
如果这里所有的x1到xn
和y1到yn
都是无限长度的随机的一个stream
这个应该是理论上是安全的
因为你没有办法去穷取去试这个yj
但是在现实生活中
这里头的x1xn到xn y1到yn
它是一些人的id或者是phone number
对吧
或者是身份证号码
那这个它都是一些low entropy的
对不对
它都是能够被穷取计算出来的
所以在这个里面
这个就不够安全了
为什么
因为如果是这里面的所有的远速
数据集合是这种low entropy
也就是它是有限的话
那么就还是刚才那个例子
hxj我没有receiver
不知道hxj是啥对吧
那我知道这个yj是举个例子
身份证号
那我把所有的身份证号都拿去h4一遍
我就能够有一个结果
有一个yj
有一个身份证号的hxj的结果
跟这个一样
那那个身份证号
肯定就是这个yj
对不对
这个唯一性
所以这个就从这个的实际的应用中
这种hash-based的这种收入是
它是肯定不安全了
好
那我们现在想
我们看了一个不安全的
这种很简单的
那意义的这种hash-based的这种psi
那我们想一想
我们来设计一个真正安全怎么做
我给大家先讲一个
比较简单的这种psi
它是bass的definham kick exchanger的一种
协议的psi
definham kick exchanger
是有介绍的
大家可以到reference里头去看
然后它的核心
这想法我给大家提来出来了
它想法是什么
就是Alice Bob
我把自己的元素
我都要去加密
各自加密一次
所以有一种感觉
像一种double encryption一样
但这个double encryption
很有特点
它满足一个交换率
所以Alice先加密
玩自己的一个元素
给Bob
Bob再加密自己的元素
再给Alice
然后两人再把对方给的这个元素
再各自加密一次
这里是可以满足交换率
这个如果是元素相同
它加密出来的元素
还是一样的
跟这个谁先加密
和谁后加密这个顺序
不影响
这里面加密这个词
我用的是比较不正式的
这个其实不能算是一种加密的协议
但这个用这个词
大家更好理解一些
大家粗想
就是如果我有这么一种
两次加密的方案
而且它满足交换率
是不是我有可能就能设计一个PSI呢
如果我有这么一个协议
那么Hiding是怎么做
Hiding就是我加密了
Alice加密的元素
我给Bob看不到
对不对
哇
能在Alice加密的这个
至上的密文再做一次加密
但是我不知道你这个加密的原始的名义是什么
所以这个increase has elements
那Comparing刚才说了
这个交换率
Communitative property
所以我如果有同一个元素
或者各自两次加密完了
那我只如果这个两个元素是一样的
那它们这个
虽然加密的顺序不一样
那它还是结果是一样的
然后效率呢
效率来说
其实这种
DVHelmkey exchange base的这种PSI呢
它大家能想到说
各自加密对比
这个certain common occasion cost
是个linear
跟你的这个元素的个数是线性的
而且其实呢
这种DH base的这种PSI
就DVHelmkey base
它现在还是一个主流的PSI的应用
原因是什么
原因是很多这种
DVHelmkey里的一些密码
原语的这种提升呢
就会直接造成DH base的PSI的提升
所以我提升的这个
假如说我有些新的这个
底层的DVHelmkey的一些密码
原语
那么这些新的原语更高效
那这个PSI也就更高效了
好
我们下来来看一个具体的
我们怎么去设计这么一个方法
首先我先大概介绍一下
DVHelmkey exchange
用密码学的数语
把它大概讲一下
它一般是基于一个叫
discrete logarithm problem
就DLP的这么一个hard problem
这个里面呢
就是说有PEGXY
就是大家简单想
就四个非常大的这个整处
整整处
然后其实还满足一个什么的
GDX方等于外模P
这是一个
密码学的常用的一个
球模的这么一个运算
P需要是一个很大的prime number
那么hard problem什么
hard problem
就是说我给你YGP
你想要找到X是个很难的事情
它满足什么
就是说我去计算
借X模P的时候是很简单的
但是呢
这个就是满足Efficiency的条件
也就是我之前刚才说的
这个比较高效
对不对
但是呢
我如果想拿到
我拿到YGP了
我想求这个指数X
在我刚才给的这么多
这些数字的限制条件下
这个是很难的
这个就是Heading
然后呢
这里需要强调一下
真正的PSI
机遇的密码的sumption
和只能是说
是机遇DLP的
但它其实还是不是DLP
它是Decision Development的
一个sumption
就是那是另外的
就是一个机遇DLP的一个变形
大家可以这样理解
密码学的一个sumption的变形
但我们其实理解的这个DLP
其实就可以理解
BHBase的PSI是怎么样去计算的
所以这一块
我把更多的那种密码学的
那种推荡的细节
我这里就不讲了
然后第三个部分
其实是很重要的
就是要能comparant对吧
其实就是那个交换力
交换力什么意思呢
GXY模P和GYX模P
它其实应该是同一个东西
也就是满足comparant的性质
这里就是再强调一下
我刚才所有讲的这些书
它肯定是要满足一些密码学的条件的
这些条件都是很苛刻的
没有满足密码学里
任意一个条件
那么DLP或者基于DLP的DVL的sumption
可能就不够安全
但这些细节的条件
我这里都不去讲了
因为我们理解了这些
大的DLP怎么设计
怎么做
我们就能理解PSI了
这个并不影响我们理解PSI这些密码学的细节
DVL的PSI它是什么样子做的呢
就刚才我们已经讲了对不对
那就那几步
其实很简单
Receiver一个X
散掉一个Y
然后它各自有一个随机密码A跟B
Receiver怎么做
它先把自己所有的元素通过X
用DLP先这样算一下
H其实是把这个元素
它map到了一个特定的group上
这都是一些密码学的
先定条件
这里就不细节讲了
但简单想
就是我因为DLP的原因
对吧
我把所有的元素做完哈奇之后
再把它呈上一个指数密码A
我把它送过去
Sunder是没办法去反对出X1到Xn的
对吧
真的蛮足开顶的条件了
然后接着是交换率的条件
Sunder可以干什么呢
Sunder可以对所有Receiver送过来的HX
I的这些A字方
然后它把B在作为指数乘上去
然后送回去
送回给Receiver
同时Sunder再把自己所有的元素
也拿1到Yn
拿自己的密码再算一遍送回去
因为满足交换率对不对
所以Receiver它把HY1到Yn的B
B字方它乘个A
然后它再跟Sunder送回来的AXI的AB
虽然这里头
大家能看一下
举个例子就XI
它是先用A加密再用B
Yj是先B加密再用A
因为满足交换率
它结果如果XI跟Yj是同一个元素
那么HXIAB和HYjBA
它的结果应该是一样的
因为是交换率保证的
所以我这样可以比较出来
相同的元素
如果不同的元素怎么办
不同的元素
因为是两边各自加密的
Receiver它是看不到Sunder的那些
不同的元素的
因为Sunder是已经加密过一次了
好
这是第二个方法
然后第三个方法
我稍微再讲一个进阶版的PSI
它叫OPRF-based的PSI
它还是很有意思
也是很著名的一个思想了
就是这也是一个在PSI的学术领地里头
一个比较著名的分支
Protocol的细节
大家可以参考Reference Bible
我这里还是把High Level Ideas讲了一下
首先这个想法还是很类似
大家看这个PSI设计都很类似
首先Sunder它也是要想办法
不能去计算一个Secret Function
这个Secret Function是它自己来可以计算的
它一个人就可以计算
它算完之后
它把自己的Secret Function
根据它的数据计算完之后
可以送给Receiver
Receiver也要计算相同的Secret Function
但是它不能自己计算
它需要跟Sunder去交互
来算这么一个东西
Receiver算的Secret Function
也是基于Receiver自己的数据级
然后Receiver算完之后
因为它拿到了自己数据级的Secret Function
计算结果
和Sunder数据级Secret Function计算结果
它两个一比较就知道这个结果了
这就是一个最基础的
看刚才那个很类似的这么一个想法的
PSI设计的概念
Hiding是怎么保证的
Secret Function
保证的就是Sunder在算
跟Receiver交互算Receiver的
Secret Function的数据级的时候
它是不能够看到Receiver的data的
然后Receiver要求什么Receiver
是不能够知道这个Secret Function
是怎么样算
然后Comparing
其实就是Sunder跟Receiver
它们各自数据级
经过同一个Secret Function计算
应该是如果是同一个数
就是相当大
然后Efficiency
其实就是OPRF-based的这种PSI
它里头大量的运算
都是这种哈西
或者是Symmetric Key Encryption
这也是一个密码学数据
大概就是说这种比较常用的
这种加密的这种
对称密要加密
然后其实里头是很少的
这种非对称密要的运算
所以它效率也是很高的
那么我们先来看一下
怎么设计什么一个协议
所以这个协议里头
核心就是Secret Function
对不对
这个Secret Function
我们把它叫Oblivar
Secret Random Function OPRF
它的核心是说
我们我有一个Key
Sender有一个Key
然后它有一个Input from receiver
然后他们可以交互来算FKE
就是Sender提供一个Key
然后Receiver提供一个Input
我算了一个
基于OPRF的这么FKE
要求是密码安全
安全区就是什么
Receiver不能够
看到这个结果对不对
FKE是给Sender的
Receiver不能知道结果
而且Receiver它本身是
不能够去知道这个Key是怎么算的
那因为是Receiver提供的数据对不对
那么Sender肯定是不能知道
Receiver这个Element的意义是什么的
所以这就是一个OPRF
就是把刚才我说的那个Secret Function
把它具体化了
就是这么一个
我们需要设计这么一个方式
然后如果有了这么一个方式
我们怎么设计PSI呢
那么就很简单对不对
Receiver拿这个OPRF去做Evaluate
在他自己的数据机上
通过跟Sender做一个交互对不对
Receiver是不能知道Sender的Key的
但是Sender不能
不会知道Receiver的数据机
这是最基本的要求
然后Sender接着
因为他是知道这个OPRF的
他就在自己所有数据机上
自己的数据机拿OPRF做一次Evaluation
把结果送给Receiver
然后Receiver就通过OPRF
把自己的数据的这个结果
和Sender数据的结果做个对比
他就知道一样还是不一样了
所以我们先看一个图
这就是一个OPRF
基于的那个PSI的协议的这个势力图
Receiver是on x
Sender是y
然后对于这边的每一个Receiver的一个XI
那么我都要通过一个
这个因为Sender这边是有N的元素对吧
我都要设计一个Key
然后用OPRF调用N次
然后对每一个XI
我都要计算这个所有的这个
因为我不知道哪一个元素跟这边相的
所以我要计算N次
所有的这个Y1到Yn的
基于这个不同Key的这个XI的这个值
然后那个同时我对于自己这个不同的这个Key
我要也要把自己的所有数据机算一遍
然后我把这个结果送完给这个Receiver
Receiver呢
拿到这个数据机
就是说大家两边的结果的时候
他要做对比
大家能感觉到这块肯定是要做N
品房次对比对不对
因为这边是基于每一个XI
我都要去算这个N次
所以是N房次对比
然后安全呢是OPRF来保证的
然后Performance呢
Performance刚才说了这个
大家能看出来啊
这个肯定是计算
计算效率跟那个computation
和computation cost都是很高的
这个原因是什么
就是因为Sender和Receiver之间
不知道哪些数据是相等的对吧
所以我都要算
各自都要算N次
所以这都是N平方的这种
计算和comparison
那么我怎么样才能提高这个效率呢
最简单的一个方法
就是肯定是用哈希对不对
我哈希完了
hash完了都在一个病里头
这样我就比较我比较病就行了
我不用比较所有的元素了
这是一个整个论文OPRF
Base的Pi在论文里提出的一个思想
这个思想就是我这边呢
Receiver用一个这个coco hash
coco hash
我大概讲讲解一下coco hash
什么coco hash就是我拿到一个
这个元素
我想去把它insert到这个hash table里的时候
我如果insert进去之后拿
拿第一个hash function
我insert进去之后
第二个hash function进去
如果有个conflict
我就把第一个结果拿出来
用另外一个
或者其他的hash function再算一遍
所以这样就是能够保证没有conflict的
然后我插到这些病里头
然后Receiver sender那边呢
用的是这个simple hash
simple hash就是我把所有的
集合multiple的hash function
每一个hash function
我都把这个元素计算一遍
然后插进去
然后做完之后呢
我们能看到如果这样做完之后
这个比较
是不是肯定就是这个Ons比较了
因为整个的我这种病里头
我计算这个病里头的OPRF
和比较就可以了
我不需要去把所有的元素
就是用m方式这样去计算和比较了
所以呢
这个就是kkrt
就是刚说的那个OPRF
Base的psi的一个prologal
hashReceiver跟sender还是这样的
然后Receiver像我刚才讲的
他coco insert
把自己的n个元素放到一个table里头
sender是simple insert
simple hash把这个元素放到一个
table里头
然后对每一个病呢
然后这个sender跟receiver发起一次这个交互
这个交互里头
这个
这个里头v1
大家注意是v1到v2
他这个里头应该有
是有一些这个计算参数
已经是不是原来的
1到1了
这个里头会小很多
所以通过这
病里头每一个病里的这个计算
然后和病的长度这里头是相关的
然后通过这个计算呢
我就可以对每一个病我里头
这个结果我做一个OPRF
然后两边做一个比较
就可能知道这个病里头是不是某一个元素
相等
想法还是sender把自己的都算完
然后送给receiver
receiver
去和sender做一个交互
我发起后PRF来算自己的所有元素
然后做对比
数数每一个病的结果就可以了
大家能看到这里头
里头有一些参数气质
大家可以参照论文
但大概率就是
核心上
因为这些参数的这个选择
就是hash table
病的这些选择
我这里面就是
已经不需要那么多次的OPRF和比较
是O文次比较
和这个
一般来说是1.5文次的
这个独立的OPRF的计算
所以这个效率就被大大的提高了
因为这个communication
conviction cost
都大大的减少了
这也就是这篇论文的这个
核心的做法
所以我给大家已经介绍了
这个三个不同的这种
OPRF的这种协议了
然后呢
大家现在可以想一下
我有一个最基本的这种
two party的这种
Semi honest的这种
半诚实的secure的psi
我可以用到用来做什么对不对
首先最基本的
我可能可以用它来做黑白名单
对吧
这个是大家很多人知道
然后状酷呢
也是一个很重要的
这个psi的一个应用
因为在现在一次计算中
如果是vertical partition的data
就不管是联合建构
还是联合数据分析
它产生第一步是需要
找到这个common的user set
所以就是状酷
有很多应用
大家能不能想到
那问题是
还有什么
我们还需要什么呢
首先第一个
我们想到了
能想的对不对
刚才介绍了这些协议
我里面都是说交集
是能够用的
交集是两边都能够看到了
或者至少一方能看到的
像sender receiver
就是receiver他能看到
如果是那个psi
defehumbon basepsi
就是两边可能都可以看到
那么如果交集不能看到
怎么办
所以对交集
我们可能会有一些
更tricky
更高界的使用的方法
第二个就是很简单
这都是两方的对吧
那我们如果三方四方怎么办
或者是不是有一些特殊的多方呢
第三个就是计算模型
刚才说了
就是我这种
计算都是一方或者两方能知道
那如果是
这个一这两方
他没有办法
都没有办法
算是需要有一个server来a的
那这种情况怎么办呢
第四个当然就安全模型
因为这都是半城市的这个psi
那如果是恶意安全psi怎么办
第五个这个
变形是什么
就是说我刚才这里头
sender receiver isbob
我都是讲的他们N个元素
元素是相等的
那如果有一方特别多
去个例子
他一方有11个元素
另外一方只有
一百万个元素
两边这个差特别大
那你用这种常规的psi
效率还好吗
还是说有更高效的psi呢
这一块也可以给大家介绍一下
所以交集的使用
他的动机是什么
交集使用动机
就是说
这个交集有可能
他并不是两方的一个common knowledge
这就是打破了常规psi的
最初的那个假设
什么意思呢
这个在交集中的数据
他可能是属于一些其他人的
第三方的
举个例子
就是iLIS他有一个账户
他在银行A和银行B都有一个账户
然后他用他同一个ID
然后他注册了
所以呢
银行A跟银行B如果发起一次psi
他们互相看不到对方
各自特有的这个用户
这是ok的
对吧
这是psi最基本的对应
他们能找到iLIS
那么iLIS在两边各有账户
银行A跟银行B通过psi
找到发现iLIS是个common的一个user
这个ok吗
这个应该是depend对不对
iLIS如果签了一些协议说
ok
你们两个发现我是common的user
是ok的
那是ok的
但如果iLIS没有签这样协议
所以尽管A有他的账户
那么iLIS可能并不愿意向B看到
同样的B有iLIS的账户
iLIS也并没有说B
你可以看到我在A有账户
所以这个就是
这个交集就不能够直接这样被拿来用了
所以这个里头的challenge是什么
有可能交集我们需要可用
但是不可见
第一个case是什么
第一个case是交集的是
秘密的
就亢别单手
我是不能用的
但是Cardinality是可以用的
Cardinality是什么
Cardinality就是这个交集里头元素的个数
这个也是其实符合很多大家通常的这种思维
对吧
就是因为交集的元素的个数
是一种统计的信息
在大多数情况下
它是一种统计的信息
那么这种统计的信息
很大概率是大家可以直接拿来用的
所以交集的个数
元素的个数是可以被泄露
给一个authorized party的
那方法是什么
方法是有一个用同态和pollinomial evaluation
这个referenced有
这个思想也是比较直观的
可以来算这个交集的个数
同样如果用BVHelm base PSI
如果我把两边的交集里面的这些元素
我之前safo过的话
reference20里头会有
就是里头会讲如果做了safo
其实是没有办法知道交集是谁了
但我还是会知道各处是什么
然后第二个case是什么
第二个case是交集是
秘密的
交集是秘密的
然后我交集里面
我是想通过这些交集
能算一些follow up的这种computation
是和这些交集它一些相关的数据
什么意思呢
什么意思就是说
我交集是个加密的
但是每一个交集
举个例子
这些交集是一些人对吧
这个共同的人群
这些交集里的这些共同人群
他每个人都有一些其他的数据
可能是什么收入
什么年龄
这些数据
我想其实想算的不是
我允许看的不是交集的人群
那这些人是谁
但是我是想知道这一群人
他跟的对这些数据的一些统计信息
这个是允许了
所以呢
这个是PSI with payload on intersection
这也是一类论文
所以PSI本身是个hidden的一个中间的结果
但是这些PSIhidden的这些palo的
也就是这些可能是一些人跟的
的这些额外的数据
我是想去计算的
举个例子
计算他们什么收入的盒
或者平均收入什么的
这个都是很常见的这种应用
方法是什么
方法是reference那里头有一个
就是电路base的psi
这也是比较常用的一类psi
他跟npc很接近
是把这个结果把它去放到的一个
电路里头
加密的电路里头
那个电路里头
每一个电路里头
我看不到交集
因为他是加密的
但这些交集他背后跟的这些数据
也是在电路里头加密的
但我可以对于他做一些统计的运算
还有就是刚才说的
dfmbase的psi
那个20里头也说
如果用一些半能态
我可以把这些数据加起来
可能是比较Limited的计算
只能算一些和
但是也是可以算了
第三个情况是说交集是
隐私的
R不能看
但我们还要用
这感觉是一个非常矛盾的一个说法
对不对
他方法是什么
方法是说
就是首先这个multibation
我一会会在
因为这一类的所有的这种psi
这一类的k3的这种psi
他都需要和差分隐私去配合
我一会会在psi和其他隐私计算的
这个技术结合率
会详细介绍一下
但核心就是说
我交集的统计
每一个交集里的个体
我不能看到
我不能确定是不是交集
但是交集统计信息
我是可以用的
那么就可以用同态psi
然后差分隐私
这是一篇论文里讲到的
然后还有一类
就是deepfinal的basepsi和差分隐私
这是我们现在团队正在开发的
一类协议
这个也是能够做到的
然后多方psi
多方psi
首先有一个常规的这种多方psi
他想法是什么
想法就是说
我用n个party再做psi
对不对
那么只有这n个party
就是n可能是大于20个345这么一个数字
只有多方的所有的用户的交集
我才能够被看到
也才能够被用
那么challenge是什么
challenge就是说
我刚才说的这些psi都两方的
你直接用两方来算
多方是不行的
原因是
你两方的时候
任意两方的数据
可能是能够被看到的
对不对
就是如果一个两方的psi
被另外一方或者
或者这两方两个参与方期中
一个看到了
这个已经不符合多方的定义了
多方是只有这真正的n方的交集
才能被看到
所以方法也是
Ater里头有一个referenceAter里头
有一个方法是同态加
polynomial representation
还有一类比较新的是
基于opprf
programmable opprf的这种思路
也是可以做到的
还有一类比较特殊的多方
我稍微介绍一下
这个是跟业务
很多业务相关的
在业务里头
有可能这个交集
我不是说让有多方来参与
对不对
但在多方里头
我这个交集可能说
我想让其中某一方看到怎么办
那么这个challenge是什么
challenge之后
这一类的协议
他的要求是case by case
就不一定是固定的一个情况
所以需要去customize
的密码的solution
方法也是没有固定的
就是说如果我多方
其中的交集有可能是
我两方让一个
另外一个人看到
或者说我三方让一个
什么人看到跟需求
安全的需求是强项关的
需要去特定的设计这个协议
计算模型是
首先刚才大家看到
Alice Bob
Client Server这种
他可能都是一个
弯位的model对吧
Motivation是
只有一方能看到交集
这个也很容易想到
就是如果说一个Client
把自己的contact list
给个social media service
那么只有client是能够看到的
对吧
理论上这个social media service
他是不能看到client和他的
这个交集的
方法也是我刚才讲的
这个oprf
就client server这种本身
就是一种弯位的model
还有muchlmodel是什么
muchlmodel就是两方
他一起能看到这个交集的
这个其实也比较简单
的应用
来说就说common user
两个bank
他都想找到共同的用户
对吧
假如说这些用户是让他们
允许他们看的
那方法呢
方法就是dfml
那个如果是两边
这个都去执行
是一个对称的执行的话
就是一个muchlmodel
然后在半成时安全的
这个模型下
因为你假定大家
都是严格执行协议
不会做这种
额外的恶意攻击
那么其实
就是这种oprf
Base of protocol
他一方算完了
client算完
他把结果告server
也是可以了
这个都是ok的
那么还有什么特殊的计算模型呢
还有一类psi叫out sourced
或者叫delegated server
added psi
他其实都指的一种
就是说我两个client
去执行psi协议
但是他需要一个
第三方的一个帮助
这个第三方又不能信任
不能直接信任他
举一个例子
这两个client
就是他们都是什么
他们都是resourced
client devices
可能是举个例子手机
他们没办法算这种大量的计算
那么他需要一个什么
他需要一个
第三方来帮助他们计算
但要求肯定是说什么
第三方是能够提供这种计算的帮助
举个例子
他可能是个语音服务商对不对
但是呢
这个第三方本身
是不应该能够看到这个结果的
所以这个一般来说
这种他的思想是什么
思想就说这个
我有一个语音啊
举个例子
这是最常见的
云我来帮助两个psi的这个参与方
来计算了这个psi
然后他算完出来是一个加密的
前面这个highway的
看别增长计算完
这个加密的数据送给这两个
这个这个
参与方了
参与方然后来解密
就得到了这个结果
然后这个语音在这个计算过程中
他是应该不能看到任何
这个跟这个交集相关的信息的
那方法是什么呢
方法也是这个12里头会有一个方法
他就是用了那个pollinoma
repentation加那个同态和prf
就可以做到这个
然后下一个这个变形式安全模型
安全模型我刚才所有讲到的这些
全都是半程式安全
半程式安全
大家能看到他相对来说
简单对吧
因为我定义了这个攻击率
他只能严格执行协议
可能会做一些分析
但是我还是需要严格执行协议
不能任意攻击
那么他就是简单高效
然后大部分的这种现在的
隐私计算里使用的这种psi
都是这种半程式模型的
那问题是什么问题
很简单
这种安全假设太强了
也就是说这个是个比较弱的安全模型
因为这个攻击人
他像攻击还得要follow这个
这个执行
就是严格的执行这个协议
不能随便篡来这个协议
这是一个很怎么说
很很强的一个安全假设
所以方法的刚才所有讲的
全都是这样的安全模型
那么大家肯定能想到
我如果假的这个攻击人有更强的能力
那么肯定就有这种恶意的
这种secure的psi
他的想法就是
这种我要有一个更高的安全性
同时
这是一种更符合实际情况的
安全假设对不对
也就是说我这个攻击人
他可以做正义的攻击
这个里面的这个攻击人的定义
就是说这个攻击人
我不用去严格执行协议
我可能会去篡改中间结果
或者说是我把一些错的数据发出去
或者我有一步
我不做了
我停掉了
我是任何的几事情
他都可以去破坏这个协议
大家肯定能想到
那这这样就很难对吧
很难去阻止这个攻击人的攻击了
所以一定是需要更多的计算
和这个communication
或者还得去做什么
能去做一些extra的这种replication
就每一步我都需要一些额外的
独立的兴趣去verify
你没有去违背这个协议
你是严格执行协议的
一旦攻击人他违背的这个协议
那么这些extra的verification
这些额外的验证
就会把这个攻击人的行为暴露出来
然后大家可能就会停掉了
好
下一个是非对称的这个psi
非对称psi呢
还是说的是
就是如果有一方啊
他的这个psi
他的这个number
比另外一方多很多
怎么办
这个也是常见的
对吧
client的solar模型
我client有一些
好
比如说有一些contact list
我solar里都是可能上千万上一的
这个contact list
那这种情况下怎么做呢
大部分呢
就是说这种
实际的这个应用场景里的这种psi
其实都是这种非对称psi
因为很有可能一方的数据
和另外一方比
会少很多
他的这个这个挑战性在哪
是一
就说一般的这种常规psi
就像刚才呢
Alice Boba的
假设各有恩怨元素
那么他用到这种
两边的这个数据元素
以及不对称的情况下
他的效率都很低
所以我们需要额外设计
幸运的是
我们也有很多方法了
举个所谓举个例子
就是EC0 PRF basepsi
这个里头想法是什么
就是用cash的这个思想
把大的这个数据机我cash掉
然后
只是去计算这个small
就是那个很小的数据机
我每一次有变化
就算他
那么这个就小多了
对不对
同时那个全同态的
这两篇文章
也是非常好的
他去算这种
非对胜psi的
这个很高效的算法
核心肯定是说
这个这个最highv的这些计算
是在那个小的数据机上
而不是大的数据机
好
下面我们在
第三部分看一下
psi的一起
那个最新的进展
刚才我们讲到的是这个分类
然后最新进展
我这里大概提一下
最新进展
首先第一个是说
我们刚才看到这个psi
他基于了很多这种oprf
什么这个
这些里面他一般很多
他用的一些底层的密码
源于都会分成offline
online两个部分
offline的部分
怎么样去优化呢
是有一些可以用一些
更高效的
更好的
最新的一些oT
这也是一个密码学源
大家可以具体参考这个论文
去学习一下细节
或者我把这个底层的一些密码
学源
换成其他的更高效的
VLE的这种源于
还有一类就是
刚才大家看到了
就是这种offlineonline
这种这种计算之外
我还有一个核心的增加效率的方法
这种coco hash
对不对
这样我在并里头做计算和比较就行了
那么有没有什么方法
我们把这个病
这个coco hash
哈希的这个方法换掉呢
也是有的
可以用pactos
或者是okvs
这也是一些其他的更高效的
这个coding decoding
或者是这种类似的这种思想
能够把这个数据压缩
极度的压缩
然后来计算效率会变得很高
第三类是说
还有一些这种安全计算的
这种模型
我就是刚才提到的
我不一定是能看焦急
对不对
那么如果是我不能看焦急
那我有可能是
pprf
programmable
对这种oprf
或者是这种用差分以资
来做这种psi
这个也是一类发展的趋势了
那总结来说
psi是一个
我刚才提到了
是最简单的多方圆计算的一种变形了
可以说
然后它现在一级计算
如果我在假定高带宽
和高算力的情况下
经常一级的psi
半成时是可以在分钟级别完成的
可能恶意的话
可能会慢一些
但是这一块一直是发展
相对比较高效
也是比较容易实施落地的一个技术分支
应该是说
最实用的隐私计算方法之一
而且它也是用的最广的方法
好
我最第四部分
我再介绍一下psi
和其他一些隐私计算的技术的结合了
首先psi和差分隐私的结合
差分隐私
我这里很粗的介绍一下
我们应该还有穆克会专门讲差分隐私
就是说不正规的讲差分隐私是什么
差分隐私
就是我在一个数据队的添加噪音
这样你就很难够
很难去决定
是不是有某一个元素
一定在这个交集中
所以他是保护个体的
大家注意差分隐私是保护个体元素的
但是统计上来说
Statistical上
统计手学上来说
这个data set
还是满足他原来的特性的
就是我加了噪音保护了个体元素
那么刚才我们提到了
如果psi这个交集
我们又想用
又需要用
但又不能看个体怎么办
什么意思呢
就是说这里我们的想法
就是我们可以把这种差分隐私的噪音
加到这个交集里头
这样呢
就交集里头
统计统计上来说
这个整个交集是两边的一个交集
对不对
但是你拿出来交集的任何一个元素
你说这一个元素
是不是一定是交集中的
是
Iless也是保护的
那么不一定
因为这个是有差分隐私保护的
是dp hard的
去determine
是不是某一个元素肯定是交集的
所以这个这样
我们每一个个体的元素都受到了保护
因为你不能确定
这个个体元素是不是交集中的一个元素
但是整个这个交集统计上来说
它是交集
这个呢
就是刚才我提到的就是个体元素受到保护了
然后这个也是有很广的用途
就像这种giant marketing
就是打广告对吧
就联合营销里的
我用到的就是这一个交集的人群
或者两个银行
他给共同的用户打广告
那么我就是用到这些共同的人的这些ID
但是这些人我又不能知道具体每个人是谁
那么我加了噪音
我去挡了这个广告
从统计区学上来说
这个交集打广告是ok的
因为大部分人都是交集中的
但每一个具体
具体每一个人是不是是交集中的
不一定
所以我也没有侵犯这一个个人的意思
然后他的难点是什么呢
如果我设计这么一个协议
难点是说
我这些交集啊
他都是加密的
因为我不能明确的看到
那么有意放
还需要在加密的这个交集里头
去添加这个
false positive
跟 false negative
这是非常 challenge 的一个事情
然后方法是什么
就是全同态加DP
是有一个方法可以做的
然后同时啊
但这这种方法
他是效率不差的
但是同时用 dvharm.bsi 加DP
也是可以做的
这是我们团队正在开发的一个方法
然后啊
case 2 呢
是说啊
我现在有差分一次这个思想了
对不对
这个reference
一拼里头就有
那么
我刚才提到的 oprf
很多这种啊
psi 计算里头
我都需要有这个并
并里头有一个常用的思想
就是 padding padding
把一些那种大密 element
的pad 到里头
然后来那个提供一次
但是如果有差分一次的保护了
我可能不用去
每一次把这个大密 element
就pad 到最长
我只用有一个固定长度就行了
这个思想跟上面这个类似啊
一样是说
因为有差分一次的保护我每个具体的元素
我都已经受到保护了
所以那么我这个可能去
计算的时候
我的这些效率是可以提高的
另外一个就是
有一个叫masa te
它是安全交集
跟可新执行环境的一种结合了
可新执行环境是一种基于硬件的
这个环境了
我这里快可以讲一下
这个想想吧
很简单
其实就是用te
去制造一些盐
把这些盐给每一个party
然后party
因为有盐了
他们去把自己的元素跟盐放到一起
做个psi
然后psi是在te这里完成的
因为有盐的
他们互相是不能推
推出来这个原始的元素是什么了
当然te
te是可以
但是我们有假能te是可以信任的
对吧
然后结果是可以送完给party了
这个就是一个很简单
也是有效
可能说灵活的方法
但问题是什么是很简单
就是一种密码学的事物
这个不是一个密码学的solution
因为它的trust的入口是te
也就是提供盐的te
它必须是可信的
才可以
这也是一个安全巧交级
跟其他一些计算技术
结合的这么一个例子
这个也是开源的
好
就是我已经介绍了psi的几个技术分类
功能
包括最新的发展
还有一些定义
包括和其他技术结合
那么这个是reference list
我这个这一讲里头提到的psi的
绝大部分
著名论文和最新的论文在这里头
都有列举
有兴趣的同学
下来可以根据这些论文
再进去学一些细节
好的
那么这就是第一讲安全
巧交级psi的讲解部分